good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I'm
very proud to welcome you to this edition
of our 2022-2023 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school of data
science and through a grants from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences since
2016 the foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of data
science methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling as they
pertain to different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's chosen theme is data
science and the public health consequences
of the covid-19 pandemic where each Friday
we enjoy presentations from leading thinkers
about the issues the promise opportunities and
the hurdles associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of covid-19
these include but are not limited to delayed
Health checkups and treatments mental health
related concerns drug abuse increased obesity and
the long lingering health effects associated with
the SARS covid-19 virus indeed our 2022-2023
application cycle is now open and we encourage
Junior faculty members working in areas such as
infectious diseases epidemiology clinical medicine
population Health as well as in data science
machine learning AI statistics and other relevant
domains to consider applying we believe this is an
exciting and engaging program where characterizing
the secondary effects of covid-19 necessitates a
unique quantitative and collaborative approach to
understanding the data associated with this very
challenging pandemic we've all are now emerging
from participants selected for our biomedical data
science Innovation lab program will Leverage The
presentations like the one you're going to hear
today as vital material oil for a culminating
in-person Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in beautiful
Seattle Washington in June of 2023. today I
am delighted to welcome our speaker Dr Adam
atherley from Virginia Commonwealth University
Dr athlete is an experienced Health Services
Research and health Economist whose research
spans numerous methodological and topical areas
including Choice modeling Health Care spending
and expenditure modeling evaluation of efforts
to improve quality of patient care and safety cost
Effectiveness analysis amongst many other things
his research often focuses on consumer decision
making regarding health insurance plan choice and
more recently value-based Health Care Dr atherley
has published more than 100 peer-reviewed research
articles and book chapters many focusing on
the health on Health Care spending he's also
an accomplished educator who has taught courses
ranging from introductory undergraduate courses
all the way through to doctoral seminars so in
concluding or sorry continuing our 2022-2023
biomedical data science seminar series theme Dr
athlete's lecture today is entitled the costs and
benefits of different covid-19 interventions
and Adam's going to be describing for us that
during the 2020-2021 time period the United States
employed a multi-faceted approach to controlling
the SARS covet II virus and to attempt to reduce
mortality and morbidity this includes non-medical
interventions aggressive vaccine deployment
and Research into more effective approaches to
medically treat covet 19. Adam's going to discuss
the incremental cost effective Effectiveness ratio
for three major covid-19 policies those
non-medical interventions the vaccine
developments and deployment and Therapeutics and
Care improvements within the hospital setting as
always we are streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube and if you are watching on
YouTube thank you so very much for joining us also
our specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and alumni are
very strongly encouraged to submit any questions
they have in the chat feature of their Zoom
sessions I will synthesize these questions
and ask them on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture and with that welcome
Adam we're super excited to hear from you thank
you so much for giving us a presentation today
uh thank you Jack so much for the
introduction I very much appreciate it
um and I appreciate the invitation to the group I
I looked through some of the prior lectures and uh
you guys are doing some really really interesting
uh work around covet 19. so as Jack said um so so
I'm Adam masterley I'm at Virginia Commonwealth
University and this is work that I did
collaboratively with uh Lena Vandenberg faltenberg
who's at the universe by a former colleague at the
University of Vermont and the the basic research
question that we're asking as Jack described was
what's the cost per quality adjusted life you're
gained of three different covid-19 policies
um now medical interventions vaccines and Hospital
health system Innovation and we really focus on
that for the first 24 months of the pandemic
and just essentially we're trying to figure
out what the cost per quality gain was was for the
different public policies that were put in place
and where this came from is so when covert first
came and we all got sent home in I guess that was
spring of 2020 it's always hard to know with
covet times um Alina vandenbrook altenberg and
I were having you know various Zoom conversations
and I think like everyone we were you know we're
at the three weeks to to bend the curve kind of
time and you know there are all of these really
unprecedented policies being put in place to try
to increase health uh for the population and we
just wanted to ask the question of what is the
cost of benefits by the way are the slides showing
up correctly Jack and Gina yes they are okay good
good um so so we just tried to that's the question
of you know well you know how much is this going
to cost and and what are the benefits likely to
be a different policy Alternatives and one of the
interesting things to us as health economists was
that especially in the early years in terms of you
know March of 2020 and in April and May there was
very little public discussion of the costs and
comparing the costs to benefits and you know
there that we just had this idea we're gonna you
know we're gonna flatten the curve and we're going
to protect the Health Care System but the sort
of Cost question never came into the discussion
and at least that we could find and so we then
started to try to think about that question
and just really do some back of the envelope um
calculations of you know well what is it likely
to look like and um the initial work that we did
was publish uh so so I email Austin fracked who's
the the editor of the incidental Economist which
is one of the blogs that the New York Times writes
we said hey can we write up a little little piece
for this and you know he said yes and so we we
just tried to do some really crude back of the
envelope calculations in terms of what are the
costs and the benefits and there were certain
three big public numbers out there that there's
the the infamous Imperial College estimate that
said that in the United States if we did nothing
there were 3.1 million people would die um the
CDC also had a model and their range was 200
000 to 1.7 million deaths um which I always
sort of translated in my head of we don't know
um it doesn't seem good but we're you know we
really have no idea of the range of it and then
the World Health Organization estimated that there
was 2.2 million deaths and so what we did then
is we just took some of the early estimates in
terms of the the costs um and really when we were
certain we were working initially with the the
stimulus packages that the Trump Administration
was putting together in Spring of 2020 and we
were sort of you know the the stimulus packages
in particular there's no economic cost for those
those are just transfers but as a reasonable proxy
for the public spending we tried to calculate it
out and you know what we came up with with those
just back the envelope calculations is that in
terms of the usual standard for what's acceptable
for a cost per quality adjusted life here gained
you know which and again the United Kingdom uh
their standard is thirty thousand pounds or about
forty two thousand dollars in the US we often use
a hundred thousand dollars as a benchmark um the
only way you could get a number in that sort of
hundred thousand dollar per quality range is if
the number of deaths was at the high end of the
potential range and the costs were at the low end
of the potential range and so just as we looked
at that we we didn't seem we sort of it sort of
almost asked more questions and then we we went
back a few months later and tried to when we had
a little bit better death and you know again we
especially on the early back of the envelope stuff
we really didn't have very good data at all so for
example when you think about the quality loss um
well we did have ages from Italy and some of the
early data in terms of the age of the average
person who died um we didn't have any kind of
quality number so we proxied that using people
with multiple chronic illnesses and so we're
our guess was that there was something like 7.8
qualities per death um you know we've got better
estimates uh later on that looked like that was
a little bit high but you know when we went back
through it again we essentially when we as we
got better data we started to get a range of
somewhere but between five hundred thousand and
six point seven million dollars per quality gain
so you know pretty far outside the usual range
in terms of what was cost Effectiveness because
again the part you know we had part of it was
that the quality estimates were better so we had
a better number there which was so we're a little
high on our first estimate and then um the costs
of course ended up being dramatically higher
than what we estimate that we first estimated
kind of surprisingly um there's really as not a
whole lot in the peer review literature sort of
asking these questions and especially early on um
and and I'll say as high and I'll flip come back
to this at the end of the talk you know in cost in
in health economics um we talk about the costs per
life here gained all the time I mean this is sort
of bread and butter stuff that we do and so it's
very odd that in this situation the sort of costs
end up being completely ignored in the peer review
literature then you know here's a little bit of a
stylized review miles at all sort of did an early
estimate and um their estimate was sort of two
hundred and thirty thousand to 3.7 million pounds
it's kind of in the same range we were looking at
and you know they sort of had the same question
we did where you know if the UK they'll pay
usually pay for equality if it costs less than 30
000 pounds per quality gained and now you've
got something that's an order of magnitude
higher which is just sort of a an interesting
issue Schoenberger at all they looked at
um they essentially tried took that standard cost
Effectiveness number and they said given how much
this is costing how many lives do we have to
save in order to justify it and their number
was something like 150 000 lives per month would
need to be justified um and again uh yakashiva
at all and I'm part of at all in that you know we
did some comparisons in terms of Life gain versus
life loss using the economic downturn to try to
calculate the number of of lives that would likely
be lost due to the decrease in societal wealth and
you know just using that very crude measure this
you know the idea was you probably gained some
lives here but we didn't really do a cost number
um and then I I thought Bianchi at all in an nber
working paper I think did a better job than we did
and they took data uh from the Great Recession and
they tried to look at how many additional deaths
came from the Great Recession and their number
was something like 800 000 additional deaths
over the next 15 years which they then applied
to the covet number which suggests that there
is going to be an extremely high number of deaths
for all kinds of reasons that are related to the
economic downturn that need to be balanced against
the lives that you're saving through the lockdowns
so as we approach this the way we thought the
way we conceptualized the cost Effectiveness to
covid-19 interventions is is that you know we
took the different things that were being done
with public policies and put them into three big
buckets and I'll go through each of the buckets
one at a time the first thing you can do so if you
can reduce the number of people who die of coven
there's essentially three things you can do first
of all you can reduce the number of people who get
covet so just keep people from getting sick from
the beginning so we do social distancing masking
lockdown school closures all those kinds of good
things so keep people apart that way they won't
infect each other and we can reduce the total
number of people who get sick the second thing
you can do is you can reduce the number of people
who are susceptible to covet 19. and really that
that's a that's code word for vaccines so you can
give people vaccines so then as a result they're
they're less likely to die of covet 19. and again
the vaccines perhaps didn't work quite as intended
um as has been fairly widely discussed but as
far as our model works as I'll talk about as
we go through here vaccines work just fine um and
then the third thing you can do is if someone does
get covid-19 you can try to keep it so that they
don't die of covet 19. so you can try to do care
Innovations to reduce the number of deaths and
those are the really you know if you think about
it from a big policy perspective keep people from
getting sick keep people from being vulnerable to
being sick or if they do get sick keep them
from dying so those are the three big buckets
so in terms of non-medical Innovations you
know obviously this is trying to limit people's
physical contact and to reduce the probability of
transmitting per individual um and it's just you
know heart it's as during the height of covet 90
of the population was told to stay at home unless
they were engaged in Essentials activities and
you know just they're they're sort of a limited
number of charts that you could show with this but
this uh here's a couple that I like um in terms
of looking at the effect of the unemployment
rate where we went from essentially the lowest
peacetime unemployment rate in our since we've
been recording statistics uh on unemployment to
the highest unemployment rate since the Great
Depression in about a month as a result of a
conscious policy choice and you know you can sort
of see all of these sharp drops where it was just
all of a sudden lots of people didn't have their
jobs and obviously that has all kinds of costs and
particularly the value of the productivity
loss that when people were staying home
the second thing that policy is this vaccine
development um the Trump Administration um put
in place operation warp speed where they wanted
to develop a vaccine for covid-19 within one year
um and I think to everybody's great surprise
you know the goal was to have 300 million
doses uh to to produce 300 million doses for
covet with initial doses available by January
of 2021 uh they there's they supported six
different vaccine companies to develop vaccines
um three vaccines were developed and approved
in under one year um all of them coming in or
two of them coming in December of 2020 and the
second in February of 2021 so just remarkably
fast development and deployment of vaccines really
very unprecedented and then the third thing is um
medical and Hospital Innovations when covet first
came hospitals really didn't have much they really
had no game plan in terms of how to treat people
with covet and so what the healthcare system did
then is they very quickly repurposed existing
treatments and they did all kinds of things
they they a lot of these were treatments that
were all already available and then there was
some process of testing them on covet 19. um they
also did a lot of changes just in clinical care
um you know doing nasal oxygen and just moving
people's physical body position on the hospital
a lot of the changes you know if you especially
the changes in clinical care there's not really
an economic cost associated with that and
putting somebody in a different position in
their hospital bed is is not an activity that
really has a dollar sign attached to it but
it made quite a difference in terms of the
probability of survival if you get coveted
so then as we looked at that Quest this question
then we we just put this in a very standard
cost-effectiveness framework where we wanted
to look at these three policy options we want
to calculate the costs and the benefits of each
of the three as individually and then calculate
the incremental cost Effectiveness ratio to
calculate the cost per quality gained now
one of the big challenges with this and actually
one of the places we got pushed back on in terms
of this the second uh it's an economist article
we get is what's the counterfactual so what is so
so we know what happened what is a reasonable
alternative world that we could think about
um and there's a couple of pieces to that you
know is for example one of the internal group
discussions that we debates that we had quite a
bit of is you know was do nothing a reasonable
realistic alternative scenarios so so what if the
government had dot said shut down restaurants had
not closed schools had not told non-essential
workers to stay home um when people have still
gone to restaurants would people still have gone
to bars would people still have gone to baseball
games um that's somewhat unknowable and you know
we could look at for example you know the last
pandemic was in 1967 where nothing was shut down
and people did did sort of act as normal did well
but that's pre-internet does that really apply to
today um there's a couple of countries that didn't
um aggressively lock down Sweden being the
most famous um but Sweden is very integrated
with countries that did lock down so you can't
really use that as a good counterfactual maybe
Taiwan and South Korea would be our best examples
of relatively isolated country well New Zealand as
well but it's a very short list it's you when you
sort of think about what would have happened if
the government hadn't done it so how would people
react and I'll come back to that point as well
um and then in terms of how we did this were the
cost we did this a review of the peer reviewing
gray literatures and we tried to make a good
estimate of what the cost of the different
policies were and if the benefits we did a
susceptible infected recovered or an sir model
so in terms of costs so starting going through
the three POS three three different policy options
um start with non-medical interventions the
big cost is the reduce GDP as a result of the
shutdowns so the way that we calculated that
number is that the Congressional budget office
does economic projections and so they actually
put out a new economic projection for the next
uh two years five years ten years uh in January
of 2020 right before the pandemic and so they
had full 2020 2021 and Beyond projections in terms
of what they thought the economy would look like
they then obviously had to revise that as as
they move forward so what we did in terms of
the GDP loss is we have the estimate from 2020
pre-covet and then we have the actual numbers of
what happened and we essentially just compared
those two now back to that question of what's
the counter factual so if the government
had said you know you can go to a baseball
game and you can go to a bar and you can go to a
restaurant that's all good um what people really
have gone um and as I say we tried very hard
to find some place in the world that had not
done anything that we could use to try to model
what the behavioral reaction would have been in
the absence of government intervention and I I
don't find anything so we assume in the end we
assume the 30 impact we assumed that you would
have seen a 30 reduction regardless of what the
government did that's really based kind of on
Taiwan and South Korea but it it's it's not a
very solid number in my view I also don't think
it particularly matters um in terms of health
care spending we it one of the pieces of this
is that how much you spend on health care for
covet will be a function of how many people get
covet so if you keep people from getting covered
through non-medical interventions you're going to
reduce some Services the other place place that
Healthcare spending is affected is when you did
the lockdown of the Health Care System there's
big reductions in delivered services and so some
care was deferred so people who were seeking care
never got it either they died or they were covered
other people delayed care so instead of getting
my cancer treatment in February of 2020 I got
my cancer treatment in February of 2021 so you
have that delayed care and then we have average
cost numbers for hospitalizations by age groups
um lots of other costs um one of the specs of
lockdown obviously is substance abuse went up
quite a bit so we have an estimate from the
literature that it went up by 12 domestic
violence went up dramatically so the estimate
is what 20 percent we also looked at increases
in child care for parents so if you have people
stay home and try to work from home that's their
kids have to something has to be done with
their kids and so we have that number in here
um school closures school closures are the
second big piece of this so there's a couple
of there there's a couple different pieces here
um first when you close the school especially in
the spring of 2020 a lot of kids just didn't get
education and so our estimate is that about that
the average kid lost about 54 days of education
in the spring of 2020. the second thing is that
as we get especially as we get into 2021 a lot of
kids transition to online learning online learning
is in general not as effective we're on online 700
session here so we don't want to say this out loud
but we will anyway so online learning is not as
effective as in-person learning and there's some
estimates from the EU in terms of the reduction
and learning associated with switching to
online they had a the the effectiveness of online
learning seemed to vary quite a bit across the EU
they had estimates where France Germany and Italy
and we took the midpoint estimate in terms of the
reduction in learning um once you have that then
what we do is we take the reduction in learning
and then that translates to a reduction in
lifetime earning and that's drawn from a study of
an Argentinian teacher strike where what they were
able to do is they were able to show that for kids
that lost 88 days of education due to the strike
they were able to actually calculate the long-term
reduction in income associated with those kids
uh and that then based on that we can get an
estimate of the lifetime reduction in at an income
associated with education there's an alternative
formulation where they look sort of look at the
years of schooling and had the effect of that
on Lifetime earning and you get a fairly similar
number so that we're using the more conservative
number here based on the Argentinian strike which
is suggesting about 500 billion dollars in in
costs as opposed to the alternative that could
do about 750 and we're doing that consistently
throughout where we're being fairly conservative
in our estimates in terms of the costs um for
vaccines we spent a lot of time um going after
all the costs that we could find so development
manufacturing purchasing deployment distribution
and since this is all publicly funded that's
actually a number that's fairly easy to get your
hands on um and there's all kinds of money sent to
all kinds of places in society to get the vaccines
out there Hospital Innovation there are a bunch of
new medications that were developed and tested and
so we had the the cost of both the development and
testing and then also the therapeutic purchase in
here in terms of benefits the benefit side again
we calculated this in the quality world and so we
did this sir model and it's a two equation model
um where there's two pieces to it there's the
change in the number of people who are infected
and that's going to be a function of the size of
the susceptible population and then the number
of people who are infected and then you're going
to have the change in the susceptible population
that's going to be a function of the number of
people who are affected and the number of people
who die now in this fairly simple model we assume
that people essentially get covered once and then
they either recover and then they're immune or
they die and that as we've learned more about
covet that's that's not quite right because the
the benefits from getting covert are going to be a
little less than we thought but to a large extent
if you get covet or if you're vaccinated for covet
um your risk is of death is dramatically lowered
and the fact that you for example might get
covered again we're looking at quality adjusted
life here's the law so we're just interested in
deaths and if you get coveted again you're sick
that's what that doesn't matter for our model
we're only interested if you survive or not and
for people who get who either recover or who are
vaccinated the probability of death is decreased
depending on who you want to believe in literature
by 80 to 90 percent so this is a fairly reasonable
approximation for how the qualities work the key
parameters in this are going to be the infection
rate so the probability of of getting coveted and
then the recovery rate so the proportion
of people uh who have coveted who survive
and then from the structural and from the sir
model we then move that to Quality gains where
again that we've now got fairly good data um
in terms of the number of average quality laws
so we each death counts for 7.85 Quality loss
that's from Briggs at all in health economics
um and then we need an assumption for what the
impact of all these different intervention is
so we assume that nmis reduce the rate of
infection by 17 that's based on a study that
was in health Affairs I guess about six or two
to nine months ago that looked at the effect of
different interventions on it and there's also a
very nice Japanese study where they showed that
same they had about a 20 decrease in infection
so we sort of see some consistent ideas that
the nmis reduce the rate of spread by about
20 percent the infection fatality rate um is
another key input and boy that was a hard number
to get our hands onto and so um there's there's
various estimates in the literature that we went
through and so we're assuming that it's initially
um 0.5 and then it gets reduced over time as the
as a healthcare system becomes more effective at
treating qualities and then in terms of the
vaccines what we did is we took actual data
on the the number and the timing of vaccinations
and we built that into our model foreign we were
also very interested in indirect effects which I
know is has been a topic within this lecture as
well and there's a whole bunch of ways that
the policies might create indirect deaths
um first obviously is care deferral so just people
who sought out care but the Health Care system was
closed so they weren't able to get it um we also
know that there was an increase in suicides and
a whole host of mental health problems associated
with the lockdowns which which would also have a
increase in deaths and then finally increases in
substance abuse domestic violence child abuse and
neglect um which which we can quantify and then
the last is increases in in preventable childhood
illnesses because of reductions in vaccination
rates when people weren't going to get their kids
their normal checkups um in terms of these now
the numbers for this it the care deferral I think
may be the big one for suicides and mental health
problems and the the other three the sort of third
through the fourth bullet there or the second
through the fourth bullet there you know we've
really it was it was big changes but in the grand
scheme of things when you're sort of comparing it
to potential millions of decides it actually ends
up being uh relatively unimportant so it doesn't
really drive the results at all on the other hand
the care deferral um is quite important in terms
of these numbers so we we know that there's
something like a 50 decrease in chemotherapy
treatment during the height of the pandemic um
and then there was somewhere between the 70 and
90 percent decrease in referrals or screening
and in terms of early results and I think we're
going to get more and more as we go on um the
early results suggest that you have somewhere
between an eight and a ten percent increase in the
death rate for cancer 15 to 16 for colon cancer
um about five percent for lung cancer and
again about 6 percent for esophageal cancer
and so those four cancers are the ones that
we focus on in terms of the indirect effects
so what we did is so we built our model and we we
have six simulated read we divided the us into six
simulated regions and we had the covet pandemic
hit our simulated regions at different times at
different points and you can see that we the the
line here the red is actual covid-19 deaths and
the blue is of what our model predicts in terms
of coping 19 deaths and you notice that they
match pretty well and they match pretty well um
because they were calibrated to match pretty well
and now I want to give you a feel for kind
of what's driving the results of this so
this is the the blue line is our prediction in
terms of the number of deaths that you would have
by week during the first year uh if you had done
nothing so this is essentially no vaccinations no
lockdowns predicting a 30 behavioral effect though
even associated with the lockdowns and then a no
hospital Innovations and then the red line is
the number of deaths that you would have had
um if you had done only non-medical Innovations
so you've just done the lockdowns and and that
kind of thing and what you see is you look at
this is the nmis decrease the number of 12 of
covert deaths that you would have had during
that first spring so during spring of 2020.
but the logic of the model is that eventually
you receive you return immunity so what that
means is you're not if you think about nmis
nmis are reducing the rate of transmission
But ultimately you're going to get to herd
immunity so the total number of people who
get sick is unchanged when you do non-medical
interventions all that you're changing is the
timing of when people get sick so you reduce the
number of people who get sick during the first
six months and then you get more people who are
sick during the second six months especially that
first winter would have been quite a bit higher
let me contrast that now I'm adding the green
ones and the green one is that if you just done
Hospital Innovation so we see that reduction in
the probability of death per hospitalization
for covet um you can see that initially it
tracks fairly well with the do nothing line and
that's because it's really the the it's really not
changing the number of people are getting sick and
it takes time for those Hospital Innovations to
take effect so that but then by the time you get
to that first winter you have two things that are
different than when you just do nmis the first is
there are more people who got sick because you had
a higher transmission rate the second thing is the
number of people who are sick are let the people
who do get sick are less likely to die that's why
you see that green line kind of dramatically below
both the blue and the red line the difference
between the blue and the green line that's that
difference in the probability of death and the
difference between the red line and the green
line is a combination of the timing of this and
the probability of the deaths and then finally if
you bring in the um the vaccines only this one's
a little harder to see because essentially the
vaccines only line is going to mimic perfectly
the do nothing line until vaccines come which
takes the first year so essentially the first year
of the pandemic would have run identically with if
you've done only vaccines too if you've done
nothing until the vaccines are actually there
once the vaccines are actually there then they
essentially damp down the pandemic fairly quickly
so put the putting those together then just
taking the three simple scenarios of do nothing
and then do nothing compared to nmis compared
to hospital improvements compared to vaccines
you know in our base model you'd lose about a
little over 10 million qualities due to cobit 19.
if you do non-medical interventions you actually
have higher quality losses alone and the reason is
because you don't really prevent quality deaths
through nmi by themselves you just change the
timing of it but you do have additional deaths
because you have failed to treat people for
cancer so essentially what happens is you you
gain a few qualities by changing the timing of
deaths it's better to die next year than this
year I think everybody would probably feels
that way so you do have a little bit of gain
when you slow down the rate of the pandemic
but it's overwhelmed by the industry by the
additional cancer deaths if you've done Hospital
improvements only you'd have about 6.4 uh million
qualities lost and again vaccines would have 8.9
this is the cost per scenario so as you look at
that first line This is the two-year GDP loss
so for do nothing there's a 500 billion actually
for for three of the four there's 500 billion uh
GDP laws so that's that 30 behavioral response
with that idea that people would have acted
differently been less likely to go to restaurants
been less likely to go to a baseball game those
kinds of things uh if if during the pandemic
than they would have done without the pandemic
um but the 1.7 trillion dollar number for mmis
that's that estimate from the CBO in terms of the
cost of the the lockdowns um the hospitalization
costs end up being largely the same vaccines keep
people out of the hospital a little bit so you
have a few little bit fewer uh hospitalizations
um but as you look at this list obviously the the
two big numbers here are the GDP loss associated
with the non-medical interventions and the
educational shutdowns so the educational
shutdowns again using our conservative number are
something in the range of 500 billion dollars so
when you look at the total cost the total
cost of the nmis ends up being 2.4 trillion
dollars and the hospital improvements and the
vaccines end up being more in the five to six
hundred billion dollar range so you sort of have
a very big you have a difference in terms of the
um order of magnitude we can also sort of combine
a lot of these things because one of the things
that you can ways you can kind of get some
play from nmis is if you do the non-medical
interventions you keep the disease from studying
through the population that delays the the delays
the number of people who get sick until say you
have Hospital Innovations or you have a vaccine
then nmis have some benefits so nmis have benefits
in keeping people from getting sick until other
interventions are in place which will then lead
to reductions in total deaths so that's why again
when you put the vaccines plus the nmi so again if
you say vaccines Only You have about 8.9 million
quality's loss if you put vaccines with nmis you
then have only 7.5 million qualities lost but you
do have to pay the penalty of deferred
care which again is a fairly big number
but you can see again here you the lowest the
lowest quality loss is when you do everything
which is kind of what we did so hospitals
nmis and vaccines and in that situation
you're going to have 5.9 million qualities
lost the highest number is just doing nmis
and so you know there's a lot of numbers here but
again we can also calculate the cost numbers and
just as you look at this this table if you look
at the bottom line in terms of total cost it's
the same basic story that if you do nothing you
know you have a cost in the 500 billion range
if you do anything if you do either hospitals
or vaccines or hospitals and vaccines you're
looking at a number in the say 600 billion
ish range and as soon as you add in that 1.7
trillion dollars associated with the lockdowns
now you've gone from the hundreds of billions to
the trillions and you really change the cost
of the program by by an order of magnitude
um this is the cost per quality gain with the
comparator being the do nothing scenario so
the do nothing again we don't have the cost per
quality game because that's our reference group
if you look at nmi so that's the third column
over Dom so dominated so nmis only have both
higher costs and more qualities lost so they're
dominated um Hospital only ends up costing about
two thousand dollars per quality gain so that's
a that's a really low cost um that so you know
that's that's the kind of cost Effectiveness you
see uh like with childhood vaccines that are well
developed I mean that's a really low cost per
quality if you look at vaccines in isolation
you're talking about 35 000 per quality
gain you know that that is cost effective
um by any standard that I know
of in sort of the the oecd world
um as soon as you add in nmis that so you start
to get numbers that are somewhere between the
hundreds of thousands of dollars per quality
gained and then the or versus and then all the
way to the millions of qualities gained so the far
right column is sort of what we did and that gives
you a number of something in the range of four
hundred thousand dollars uh per quality gained
um if we do the comparator of Hospital only
you know hospital just doing um the hospital
Innovations dominates almost everything else with
the exception of hospitals and vaccines where if
you do vaccine development on top of the hospital
Innovations you get a number of about fifty eight
thousand dollars per quality gain and then if you
add in nmi's and vaccines to at plus hospitals
compared to hospital only you get a number of
more like 3.4 million dollars per quality gain
which is kind of in the range that we were seeing
um in the early estimates that we were doing um
we did a lot of we did tornado you know we we're
we're coming up with all these parameters so we
don't really know what the distributions look
like we did tornado analyzes and the results
were pretty darn robust regardless you know that
you can do about a I think we did a 50 D um plus
or minus in terms of the nmis versus do nothing
and you can see you're gonna you're gonna the
cost per quality gain is going to range between
uh 2.4 million and 1.8 million per quality gain
so just kind of regardless of what we're doing the
nmis have a very very high cost per quality gain
um lots of limitations here and again I think
this is uh probably where in terms of the lab
you know sort of thinking about where is there
extra work to do um oh boy is there a lot um you
know the the effect of the lockdowns on the GDP is
unknown the results are somewhat sensitive to the
Assumption the trick with that sort of how strong
a behavioral assumption is that if you believe
that people would have reacted strongly regardless
of what the government did so let's say you know
we have a 30 behavioral response let's say no
no it's something like an 80 or 90 behavioral
response then in some ways what you're saying is
that the government policies were non-binding so
that meant that we're overestimating the cost but
we're also overestimating the benefits so what
you're really saying is you know if you pass a law
that you know children may not use their wings to
fly to school it doesn't really change anyone's
behavior and so you if you want to assume that
there's a the people are more sensitive to the
changes than we assume you're essentially saying
that the government rules were non-binding and
then it just sort of doesn't matter um I would
like to have a much better understanding of what
the hospital mortality rate looked like over time
um and the the data that we were pulling from the
CDC was not well risk adjusted and I worry that
the that the people who um were hospitalized
early may have been quite a bit sicker than
the people who were hospitalized later and so
if that's right then we're overestimating the
effectiveness of the of the clinical Innovations
um you know again the number of covid-19 deaths
is not well understood this has been a very
public discussion of did people die of covet
or with covet and so I think we you know be
better be we will hopefully get a much better
number in terms of what the excess mortality
rate actually looks like for covet over time
um we did not include any mental health impacts
um the unemployment is another big one and this
is back to this timing issue and I think thinking
about the timing of these interventions is really
really problematic um because we were sort
of trying to look at the scope of the whole
pandemic I'm not sure that was far enough so
you know again if you you believe the the uh
work being done by nber you know you you may
be facing up to a million additional deaths
um associated with the recession so as we move
into a new recession is it reasonable to say you
know or potentially move into a recession
um over the next year is it reasonable to
sort of charge the cost of that recessions and
the losses in terms of health of that recession
to the covid-19 policies or you know so so how
long do we want to sort of say the economic
effects are there because one thing we do know is
health and wealth are very tightly linked at both
the individual level and at the societal level
so these unemployment rates are going to have
fairly dramatic health effects um but I'm not sure
that's true of the initial one I mean so so we're
using data we we actually didn't build in any any
health effects from economic losses into our model
um and so I'm not convinced that the effect of
the coveted lockdowns would necessarily be the
same as what we've seen from the Great Recession
or previous work because it was so widespread it
was so sudden and because there were so many more
resources being sent to people who lost their jobs
um but I think it's an interesting question
there's lots of things again we didn't include
um you know overall you know we we think that
all of the options that included you know we
find is that all options include non-medical
interventions have very high cost per quality
saying save so range between forty thousand um
to several million per quality gain depending on
what scenario you do and um what the comparator
is on the other hand what the hospitals did was
very very cost effective and do in the tornado
diagrams a lot of it was actually cost reducing
um vaccines are well within the standard Benchmark
for cost Effectiveness with you know again the you
they're well with it you know depending on what
you look at which scenario you look at and the
sensitivity analysis you know we found a range
between low of maybe sixteen thousand dollars
per quality into a high of sixty thousand you
know very very very cost effective um and let's
see policy implications um timing matters um and
and thinking about the timing of these different
interventions so you have an intervention
that reduces the spread of cobit for a month
then what you know what happens do those you
know the problem is with anything that reduces
the spread of covet you are not preventing covet
you're just changing the timing of covid unless
there's some other intervention that's coming
down the line and you know again so nmis can
reduce the spread but eventually the same number
of people either get immunized or get sick
um vaccines help but only if they come in early
enough to matter and the hospital Innovation
save lives the other piece of this that's not
on here is that um the very is the changes in
the variance and the changes in The lethality of
the different variants is something that we didn't
build into it but you know our papers kind of uh
fairly deep into the review process now but if
I were to go back now I think I would you know
think about that question of how the different
variants actually may drive some of the outcomes
because one of the things you can do with nmis
is you can if there there is a variant um that's
less lethal that comes you could potentially delay
um interesting ethical dilemma I would say of you
know at wealthy countries essentially waiting for
covet to run through poor countries to develop
less lethal variants so that they can then unlock
you know sort of let themselves out so the the
ethics that there seem a little iffy um again
there's a big I think there's a very big risk
that the unintended consequences May overwhelm the
covid-19 um policy gains because for a lot of this
what you're doing is you're trading um deaths with
fairly low low qualities because the deaths for
covet tend to be concentrated in older populations
for deaths with higher qualities and again if
you look at the unemployment literature you know
the a lot of the people who die as a result of
unemployment tend to be men in their 40s and 50s
so you're essentially reducing deaths for people
in their 80s in order to increase but increasing
deaths for people in their 40s and 50s so in terms
of a quality kind of trade-offs um that doesn't
necessarily make you stronger I also want to do a
pitch we have a scope and cea calculator so it's
www.cobenceaccalculator.site my daughter was
kind enough to help me put this together and
if you don't like my assumptions
uh you know like our assumptions
um you can go to this Copa CA calculator and you
can put in your own assumptions so you can change
the the value of the different interventions that
timing of the different interventions and it'll
give you a cost per Quality quality calculation
for whatever assumptions you want to build in and
what I would really like people to do with the cea
calculator is if you believe for example that nmis
are cost effective what do you need to believe
in order for that to be true and then are you're
the things that you believe actually truth
because can you actually sort of figure out
if they are same thing if you think vaccines
were a bad idea what does that mean in terms
of the effectiveness and the Breakthrough rates
of vaccines and the timing of vaccines so really
you know my hope is that people could sort of use
the calculator to think about what they believe
um I'll also say I I think it's an an
interesting question in terms of what
this implies about cost Effectiveness and
I alluded this to this in the beginning
um you know why was cost Effectiveness just
disregarded when these policies that policies um
were done because we're able to look pretty early
on and say wow you know the cost per quality gain
um really is going to be hard to justify and so
you know what does that mean is is this just an
issue with the framework for qualities I mean
we all know qualities is a local phenomena and
you know I think one valid argument might
be just that we're really you know the the
utility curve is non-linear and we may just
be in part of the utility curve where the
average numbers are not reflected of the
reflective of the incremental gains associated
with where we are in terms of the risk of death um
it could argue that the thresholds are too low and
especially are there are the people in the United
Kingdom with the National Health Service might
want to think carefully if they're under spending
on Health Care um or is there some other reason
why why it just doesn't apply in this particular
solution and if if so why is that so I think
that's an interesting theoretical question um
I'll also say boy is that working this area hard
um and in particular the way we did it
is we sort of put things into buckets
um but if you want to look at particular
policies I think it's a really hard problem
because policies are endogenous to a troubling
event and troubling extent in a couple of ways
um first is that you know we know that we tend
to tend to put policies in place as coveted cases
increases we also know coven he has this nice
non-linear property where they Peak and then they
go down so if you put the policy in place and then
has an effect to reduce the number of infections
that has that takes place two weeks later and you
see a decrease is that because that's just the
natural run out of the illness or is that because
the policies were effective and I think it's going
to be very hard to tease out that difference um
the second thing in terms of endogeneities I I put
this picture up so this is a paper that um uh Dr
Van Brooke altenberg and I did where we compared
um beliefs and reactions to covet policies
uh between the Netherlands and the Flanders
region of Belgium which is Dutch speaking and very
similar so there's very similar cultures with with
different policies and we one of the things we
found is that there's so much variability in the
different policies that it's really you know we
wanted to do kind of a difference in differences
model to try to tease out the effect and you
trying to but the problem is there's all these
different policy options and you know the the
um Oxford put together their covid-19 government
response tracker which has all these variations
in government responses and this is just over a
short time between these two countries and you
can see you know who had the more stringent
policies well it depends on when you're talking
about um so that's hard to model and then beyond
that one of the things that we found was that
the policies that were being adopted in the
different countries were somewhat a reflection
of the belief system of the two populations and
the Dutch and the the residents of Flanders had
actually fairly different beliefs in terms of
the effectiveness of different interventions
and when it appeared as it appeared that the
governments were actually implementing policies
that were more amenable to their populations
and so then when you think about trying to affect
trying to think about the effect of the policies
are you mentioning the policy effect or are you
measuring the fact that the population thinks
this is a good policy and has already changed
their behavior in response to it and so try so
so I I think we just sort of have an unlimited
number of studies we can do but identifying
these equations to actually estimate the policy
effects these different intervention seems to me
um very very challenging and I'm about two minutes
past where we wanted but I'm gonna stop there and
ask and see if there's any questions in the
chat Adam thank you so very much this was
there is a lot to kind of chew on with this um
it's interesting to see you know you're working
with like dollar amounts I mean somebody can
really kind of understand what that means right
um and it's kind of impressive because you
mentioned like the timing of these things about
when you do these interventions and the kind
of an order in which they happen clearly not
doing anything is not a good thing depending
upon the nmis alone is maybe not a good thing
however they may buy you the time you need
to get the other interventions teed up so
that you can then deploy them and use them
in combination um and I'm curious about
um did people fully appreciate that
or you know before you've done your
analysis was that something that people kind of
understood or is this something which is sort of
you know an emerging thing that you've discovered
from your your sir modeling well I'll say it was
not obvious to me before we started and and so
so it we actually did start with an sir model
um we really just sort of said well what's going
to happen over the next two years and then as we
were trying to work through the process we just
sort of realized how important the timing of this
was which meant we had to build that entire sir
model uh to try to model it so I don't think and
I think to some extent it's still not really very
well realized because for example I see people
talk about um doing school closures now um why I
mean and let me because you're you're not gonna
you're not going to keep people from getting
we've all I mean I I know one person who's not
I had covert I mean everybody gets coveted
now um and and you can't really stop it so
you're just gonna change the timing of it I'll
say there's one exception that we don't have
in this paper and that's surge capacity so if the
hospitals run out of beds you will see an increase
in mortality rate so I think that you know if
you look at what CDC guidelines say now CDC
guidelines right as of I guess last spring or so
it basically said keep everything open unless you
have a really severe outbreak in your community
and to me the really severe means we're likely to
overwhelm the Health Care System yeah and really
that that that that that policy suggestion from
CDC is that's completely consistent with what
we're seeing as well and you know the ethical
issues that you kind of alluded to there about
maybe more wealthy companies kind of or countries
rather watching the poorer countries to see how
things fare for them and then you know reacting
inclined but that's uh I could see that happening
you know yeah I mean it's pretty public you know
the the other things in terms of ethical
issues and that that you can think about is
um looking at the data that's just come out in the
last couple of months of what's happened with the
educational numbers I think we underestimated the
educational impact in this study and the the fact
that you're having the biggest effect in terms
of loss of learning and also just people kids
disappearing from school in the lowest income
quartiles of our population means I think that
there's a lot of equity issues of these lockdowns
that need to be thought about and also I think
that the health and economic long-term health and
economic issues you know this is going to make
things like income inequality potentially quite
a bit worse for decades I think you're absolutely
right we're going to be watching this play out for
two three decades and that's the scary part to me
is that this isn't just a punctuated kind of a
problem this is going to be something which is
you know over a generation and that's you know um
incredible for our nation and for you know Nations
around the world in what happened to their gross
domestic product what happens to their Workforce
I mean it's going to be remarkable to watch that
play out over the next you know 30 40 years right
I mean and in some ways I would say public
policy just had a lot of tunnel vision you
know that that it was really about minimizing
coveted infections and covert deaths and
we we know that things like you know education
matter hugely for health and you know we know that
that economic that recessions are just terrible
you know it's like it seems it feels like a lot
of the policies sort of ignore Decades of research
you know and it's really interesting because you
mentioned this when you talked about uh operation
warp speed being some just remarkably deployed at
you know it was just so interesting how quickly it
happened and as you pointed out you know within a
year we wanted to see uh development of these uh
various vaccines and it just you know we saw this
play out with coven as a immediate need to do this
but I also kind of Wonder you know how much money
have we pumped into things like cancer where we
still don't have if necessarily effective can't
vaccines for like you know breast cancer where
you know what is the statistics like one in 11
women in their lifetime are going to be diagnosed
with breast cancer you know that's an epidemic
um you know or what is it like one in nine or
something oh it's like an epidemic level of
proportion and yet we sort of just you know we
throw little bits of money at it and we don't
have that sense of urgency which perhaps we should
yeah and and can't breast cancer in particular or
cancer in particular is sort of an interesting
example there because you know I I saw a very
nice study of Leukemia treatment starting in the
1950s that looked at the cost effectiveness of
each of the incremental treatments for leukemia
and basically every single one failed the standard
of cost Effectiveness and was not you know did the
cost per quality gain do were Justified but if you
look at a hole over the last 70 years of work
that we've done it's extremely cost effective
and when you look at the total Investments
that have been made and the total gains that
we're getting it's very so so it's sort of an an
oddity that you each incremental piece could be
not gospected while the whole thing can be cost
effective so it's interesting you know you talk
about over 70 years well you know somebody who
has breast cancer may not have 70 years to wait
um and it still may be costly for them but
nevertheless all of these things are this is
this is amazing and the amount of work that you
have have done on this is really quite incredible
one last thing I'd like to ask you about before
we have to break here is what is the continuing
role for data science and statistical modeling
and you know forecasting that's people you know
with data science computer science another
sort of degrees could contribute to to better
understand some of these uh these trends uh
I I think that there's just there's so many
numbers around in our study where I I think
broadly our conclusion is is probably right
uh no I shouldn't say probably there I actually am
quite confident that what we're finding is right
um I think if anything what we've got is we've
underestimated and I think the big question
is what are the unintended consequences of the
policies and to me that's that's maybe the most
fruitful area so again thinking about those
kids that were locked out of their schools
what's a long-term effect on their employment on
their income on their health of these kinds of
lockdowns I think that you know again when I was
looking at substance abuse domestic violence all
of those numbers they're all up and they're fairly
big numbers but again especially the preliminary
data we were looking at really you know getting
a much better feel for how you know how much of
the fentanyl epidemic is associated with covet
policies I I that's a question I have no idea
what the answer to Is but I would very much like
to um and there's a ton of work going on right
now in terms of the unintended Health consequences
for things like um like cancer deaths so again the
more we know about that is because I mean this is
a you know this is a real chance to learn um about
the effectiveness a lot of a lot of the health
care treatments in a way that we normally couldn't
learn about it and and you know we would never
say no breast cancer treatments for three months
but now we're in a situation where that kind of
where we've done that so we should learn from that
Adam matherly thank you so very much for this
uh Deep dive into the because it's just the
financial uh burden that this recent covid-19
pandemic has incurred upon us and uh these are
fascinating things lots of richness for further
analysis and and uh diving into to further tease
apart some of the nuances here of what we've
just been through and how much it cost us all
um I think that that's very important so thank
you so much and thank you to everybody who
joined us and everyone have a wonderful weekend
and uh we won't see you next week because it's
uh Memorial day but we'll see you in two
weeks since uh with another in our series
um of the foundations of
biomedical data science seminars